[Music]
around the world devices like these are
popping up in more and more of our daily
lives sex toys have become a hot
commodity in a growing Market in 2021
the world spent 19 billion dollars on
them roughly twice as much as in 2016
and practically as much as we spend on
hair care products so why is this
business suddenly booming and will the
good times last
[Music]
using devices to enhance sexual pleasure
is nothing new
some say they may have predated the
wheel
and the written word
they were touted in the Kama Sutra
some think even referenced in the Bible
the first mechanized vibrator is thought
to have been invented in Victorian Times
by Dr Joseph Granville but it wasn't
explicitly made for pleasure and you
don't need to take our word for it there
are people whose job it is to know this
stuff my name is Hallie Lieberman and
I'm a sex historian grandville's advice
was battery powered electricity was very
rare at the time and this was invented
as a medical device
vibrators were seen as things that could
stimulate the nerves so if you're
stimulating the nerves you can treat any
sort of disease now lean forward and
we'll vibrate the vertebrates
for the next Century Cure All vibrating
products could be seen on Pharmacy
shelves
and in pornography clearly vibrators
were being used for more than was
recommended on the label they know women
are getting off on this but companies
could not advertise vibrators this way
because we had all these anti-obscenity
laws so you had to sell them for a
different reason you couldn't say these
are for orgasms
you couldn't do it legally you couldn't
do it for the culture at the time
by the 1970s a more conspicuous
Marketplace for sex toys had emerged but
only really in red light districts and
as part of an industry aimed at a rather
different Cleon town
Square was you know some would call it a
cesspool some would call it a beautiful
sexual playground you have strip clubs
porno theaters peep shows almost all of
this stuff is catered to the male gays
the industry was willfully ignoring some
other eager potential customers
like this woman Dell Williams who
instead of braving the red light
district went shopping for a massager in
her local department store and the clerk
said to her
what do you want to use this vibrator
for why do you need this and she looks
like none of your business it was such
an awkward experience for her and that's
when she started Eve's Garden which was
the first women's owned sex toy shop in
the U.S
it opened around the same time that a
new wave of feminism was sweeping
through America
the Supreme Court today legalized
abortions Dell and others hoped that if
women were now more liberated they might
buy more sex toys
but for the most part they didn't join
us in the March for equality to most
women devices to enhance sexual pleasure
were still taboo it would be another 25
years before that changed thanks to a
cable TV network and four fictional
women from New York City
I'd like you to meet the rabbit thought
it would be all scary and weird but it
isn't it's it's pink for girls the
Rabbit vibrator shows up on Sex in the
City women and viewers took from this
wow that's a cool device where can I get
one a good question because buying a sex
toy still wasn't easy for a woman shops
like Eve's Garden were few and far
between more sex toys were now sold in
catalogs or at home parties but mostly
they were still to be found in CD stores
which many women just didn't want to go
into hardly surprising given that the
people who were making selling and
marketing sex toys were men the product
design was a testament to that they were
designed from a point of view of how
realistic can we get as opposed to
how much sexual pleasure can we give a
woman
but the internet would prove to be a
game changer for sex toys online
shopping made it easier for more women
to buy them even when the world was out
of pocket after the financial crisis sex
toy sales roads fast forward a decade
and things really took off
covid-19 saw a lot of people stuck at
home and open to new ways to cheer
themselves up
like buying a bicycle crafts
or a sex toy but unlike other products
that saw a lockdown boom sex toy sales
were forecast to continue growing at the
same Pace hi I'm Caitlin and I made this
film I just want to pause here for a
second to let you know that sexual
Wellness is also something that we've
written about here at the economist if
you click the link it will take you to a
fascinating article about why we think
schools and doctors should be more open
when talking about the concept of sexual
pleasure but for now back to the film so
why is the industry in such rude Health
in part because some of the people now
running it have a natural Affinity with
their customers hi I'm Simona one of the
co-founders of the oh Collective my name
is Liz my name is Anna I am the
co-founder and CEO of lioness and I'm
the co-founder and head of engineering
of lioness one of the biggest like
eye-opening moments for me was there was
a founder of a different sex toy company
and it was a CIS hetero male and I was
like how do you know what you're
building works for people with vaginas
and he was like there's this industry
standard where we put the vibration on
your nose and that's what a clitoris
feels like and I just remember having
this whole aha moment of realizing that
I had the superpower of being an
engineer we could design and build
better products that actually cater to
the needs that we have 95 of the brands
that we talk to they were all male we
actually have our doubts whether they
know what pleasure means for women
we conducted research groups with girls
and we asked them about what they like
what they don't like and girls actually
don't want anything to insert or turn up
to penetrate and especially not as a
beginner so that's why we came up with
something very small something that is
not intimidating women like Anna Liz and
Simona are also helping Rebrand sex toys
in a way that could broaden their appeal
by embracing a cultural Trend that takes
the seediness out of the industry
Wellness
what do you do to make yourself feel
good and sports was when meditation was
One Nutrition was one but then sexual
Wellness is also just a pillar of it
it's the main pillar of Wellness if you
sexually feel confident that you also
ooze that out to whatever you do an
appealing Prospect for the customer but
more importantly an easier one for
investors to get on board with the sex
toy business was once seen as risky this
sexual Wellness device Market sounds
broader safer more appealing some
investors look at investments in terms
of Trends and lioness it didn't really
fit into any of the buckets needless to
say at the very beginning it was
particularly difficult fortunately
though that's changed particularly in
the last few years where there's more
realization of
people have sex and they're willing to
buy different products and services for
sex and sexual Wellness
and with more money come more advanced
products
sex toys are going high-tech this is the
Lioness vibrator and this is what's
inside it it's the first vibrator to
contain sensors that measure pelvic
floor contractions which happen during
an orgasm the device stores that
information and sends it to an app which
lets you see your orgasms so when you're
squeezing like this you can actually see
that data in real time we always say
like knowledge is pleasure it's so
important to give people the space to
help them understand their body in their
own way in their own journey in their
own terms did you know that when you
have an O any kind of O the way that
your pelvic floor muscles squeeze and
relax during that time can be identified
in one of three unique patterns can I
show you how freaking stress makes my o
data look
with sex toys being rebranded as a tool
to promote Wellness High Street shops
can stock them without embarrassment
they're now sold even in one of the most
traditional establishments in the world
selfridges of London not something out
in the open and it's being normalized so
I think it's a huge step for the sexual
Wellness industry in general
sex toys have come a long way but their
makers still face challenges that other
Industries don't advertising for example
is tricky sextec is still categorized as
adult pornographic content and so a lot
of times we can't use the traditional
Paths of growth like doing Instagram ads
or Facebook ads I think the policies are
incredibly outdated so we've seen ads
for erectile dysfunction or things like
men's grooming kits for like their
genitals but whenever it comes to even
things like smart vibrator they're still
banned that's one of the many ways in
which this industry's fortunes are bound
up with society's changing views towards
sex there's always likely to be
resistance to it from somewhere but one
thing's clear the sex toy business is
fast becoming as normal as the desire
for sexual pleasure itself
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you for watching to read more of
our coverage on sexual Wellness please
click the link and don't forget to
subscribe